dude i just got six months man
congratulations thanks because i worry
about you
you do yeah no you don't i do do you
really
yeah like the last time
i just here's the deal dude
there's not a lot of us i mean
i'm going to give you a compliment all
right can i give you a compliment yeah
let's be real yeah
um i honestly think that you are
um
either at my level or even higher up
in terms of artistry i would agree with
part of that
and inco in comedy like that's how i
look up to you i think that
you have such an interesting voice you
and i might be doing this project
together
it's pretty big we're not going to talk
about it now but it's a very big deal
right and when i found out from these
two big people
they called me and they go it's you and
theo i was just like
there's not in my mind i'm like of
course it is
right so that being said
you know i also worry about you too you
know
because i want you here with us yeah
right
and it's like you know you and i slipped
around the same time
right yeah i didn't really i hadn't even
talked about it really because i wanted
to get six months before i really talked
about it yeah yeah and so
you know and then there was a time where
i i heard
and then you hear rumors theo was on pcp
on in nashville he ran through a wall
right you're like what he peed on a
[ __ ] [ __ ] or whatever yeah
and so then like you hear these stories
i installed pvc pipe in a wall that's
actually what happened
so that's crazy this is how it
translates so then um
and then it's just happy because i don't
also
you know want to pry into your business
yeah right because i i know that
i don't know you i don't even know who
you're seeing right now yeah
as a significant other because i just
you know that's your business but
you if you want to tell me you'll tell
me but um
yeah i'm happy to hear that dude you
know that you have
how do you feel thanks man it was hard
man it was hard to get it
it was hard to get it i mean i you know
like and i just never talk about it that
much on the like i
you know i've always been in the program
so i've never like the most i've ever
gone without a meeting is probably a
week
um but
uh but yeah i just i was in in hawaii
and they i met this dude at a smoothie
shop this shaman
and next thing you know i'm using dmt
you know at his house dude
is that real and that they ran a child
care out of there too dude
no are you really you did the mta yeah
how was it i mean
i'll tell you this man i haven't smoked
a cigarette since then
which is crazy really yes it did work
i mean i would like to say it yeah
there's no i have no doubt that it that
it that it worked man
so then dmt you did the dmt and then
that's after that you got sober
yeah so then i was just like well uh
yeah so whenever i got back home i just
got back into um
the rhythm of it yeah well i had known i
felt like a little bit before that i was
gonna
drink you know i just felt i wasn't
really doing my program as much as i
should i was going to meetings but not
doing it
and then i went to maui and just had me
uh
so a couple cocktails man nothing crazy
really i didn't do anything crazy
i never liked drinking yeah yeah so i
had just some tequila and water and
you know over a couple days and then i
ran into that man at the smoothie shop
his buddy had vitamins vitamin d3
and he hooked me up with a couple of
free bottles of vitamins and then he
he's like hey you got to meet my buddy
and then that dude just
does dmt come in a capsule how do you
smoke it what is it yeah he had like
this kind of um
little piece it was kind of a like a
peace piper kind of thing and
yeah you did it dude it was crazy and
what does it do with the feeling
here's what happened so
basically the whole way i interact with
the world is from through my eyes ears
okay suddenly like
there was no difference between like me
and like a sound
or like a color like everything was all
just the same thing
and a tree i died and then a tree grew
straight out of my mouth up straight up
into the air as high as as high as
and it wasn't even the air anymore just
like this traveling just portal into
like
i don't even know there was no maps it
was all a map
it was all a map dude it was all a sound
it was like there's no [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
there's no maps there's no like all your
senses are
just one thing like um like right now i
experience the world from me
i see i touch i have a sense of things
but suddenly i wasn't the main
i could experience everything but as
everything suddenly i'm no longer rooted
to myself
i was just part of it all man
oh [ __ ] i was part of it all i was a
piece of sunshine and i was a
so you had a like a bucket of sand and i
was like awakening
it was it was mind-boggling man it
definitely was
way relaxing in a sense like it took a
little bit of pressure off of me
yeah i want to do that thing where they
do let me know what's it called
what's it called ayahuasca ayahuasca i
want to do the acapulco dude
like i want to do it i was watching a
documentary it's called
unwell it's like a series and people
like and people are like
getting spiritual awakenings from what's
it called ayahuasca ayahuasca
and um so then i turn to kalila and i go
is that a relapse is that a relapse i
mean it counts as a relapse just because
but i think it's
for me i think it's how people count
their own time like i know anybody in
the
most people in the program would say
it's a relapse because i know a dude
that has a lot of time
and and he he said to me once
i did ayahuasca like a year ago
but i don't count it as a relapse right
so i'm like
oh [ __ ] is that allowed i don't know you
know
and i look i think all of it comes down
to how people
have their own program you know because
i want us
i want to be able to like do what you
just said like see through my eyes and
be a part of the
tree well i didn't feel like i was using
a drug i felt like
i was having a experience yeah i want to
be a part of the cosmos
yeah like i felt like i was using drugs
for hey i want to get high i want to
change how i feel because you didn't
want to probably do it again like oh
how do i get more dmt baby you know i
mean right it was just like one
experience
you weren't hooked on it right no it
wasn't hooked on it right so it's like
i want to take and and and one time
and just you know experience it and
find but then i'm i'm paranoid that i'm
going to be like a [ __ ] ayahuasca
junkie yeah
oh yeah every weekend yeah living in
living in the zoo eating [ __ ] leaves
when people come by
they'll be taking pictures of you you'll
hold on to them and they'll take a
picture of you
you know yeah or i'll have your whole
life like peacock hairs on my head and
i'll be like a shaman
yeah completely naked in the form of
peacock feathers
and i'll have like red like mascara on
right yeah and i'll be like
and just speaking some weird language
and then like you're gonna be like hey
you want a podcast
i'm you know i'm quick i'm a bird or
whatever
i'm your pituitary good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one